-Here's what people are talking
about, did you see this?
Disney's Hall of Presidents
finally added
a Donald Trump robot
to the Hall of Presidents.
Yeah, he's really making
an impact at Disney.
Today he deported Aladdin
and he gave Scrooge McDuck
a tax break.
-Really?
-Yeah.
[ Applause ]
Unbelievable.
Yeah, that's right.
They added Trump
to the Hall of Presidents.
And you can tell
it's Trump's robot,
because Putin's backstage
controlling it.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Russian accent ]
"Do not go behind the curtain."
[ Light laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] Some people
are saying the robot
doesn't really look like him.
I don't know.
See for yourself.
Here's the real President Trump.
And here is the robot.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Wait, what?
Can we do that again?
Can I see the
real President Trump?
-Here's the real one.
-The real one.
Just take a look.
If we can get that --
That's the real President Trump,
and here's the robot
right there.
[ Laughter ]
A lot of people are speaking out
about the new robot,
including Trump himself.
He said, "I am honored to be
in the Hall of Presidents,
believe me."
Then his robot spoke up
and said, "Yer! I'm hernerred
to ber in da Herl of
Prersidernts! Berlerv mer!"
[ Laughter ]
Then this old statue
of Cristiano Ronaldo spoke up
and said, "Can stertues ber
in da Herl, ter?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
Then this old statue
of Lucille Ball showed up
and said, "I wanna ger ter!
I lerv Dersney Werld!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
And finally,
this courtroom sketch
of Tom Brady said,
"Er'd rerther Ber in
da Fertberl Herl of Ferm!"
There you go.
They all...
-They all spoke up.
-...had something to say.
-Yeah, all of them.
-That's right.
Starting this week,
Trump is going to
be part of the show.
They actually made a new
commercial about the update.
Check this out.
-Disney's Hall of Presidents
has long been home
to America's greatest leaders,
like George Washington...
-I cannot tell a lie.
-...or Abraham Lincoln...
-A house divided against itself
cannot stand.
-...and starting today,
Donald J. Trump.
-God blesh the United Shtates.
-Finally, Trump stands beside
the greats like Adams,
Madison, and Jefferson.
-It's great to see
all the great children here
with their tiny little hands.
We're all born with tiny hands.
♪♪ We have small hands
after all ♪♪
-Come experience
the wonder of our nations'
most inspiring heroes.
-This is lame.
I wanna ride the tea cups.
-Disney's Hall of Presidents.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The big story today is that the
House passed the GOP tax bill.
Yep, the Senate will follow
and Trump is expected to sign it
into law this week.
Which will get awkward
when Trump says,
[ As Trump ] "I'm busy,
have my robot do it."
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Normal voice ]
That's not what he does.
[ As Trump ] Yeah.
[ Normal voice ]
It's very controversial.
In fact, I read that
a majority of Americans
would end up paying more
in taxes by the year 2027.
Trump said it's payback
for the majority of Americans
who voted for Hillary Clinton.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Yeah, a lot of people are upset.
In fact, I read that
a woman took her top off
in the House
while protesting the vote.
Security escorted her out
while Trump said,
[ As Trump ] "Let's hear
what she has to say."
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Normal voice ] I saw that
Russia's presidential election
just began with Putin
ahead in the polls.
His supporters were chanting,
[ Russian accent ] "Four more
years, four more years."
[ Normal voice ] While
his opponents were chanting,
[ Russian accent ]
"Let me out of trunk,
Let me out trunk.
Untie me!"
[ Applause ]
[ Normal voice ] You guys,
we're just five days away
from Christmas.
Do you believe that?
Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Of course, a lot of people --
A lot of people
will be flying this year.
I read that snow globes are
subject to the TSA's liquid ban.
Did you know that?
[ Audience groans ]
Which should explain things when
you see someone at security
chugging their snow globes.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Drunken voice ] "I gotta
finish it before I get on!
Then when I get through,
I'll go buy another snow globe."
[ Light laughter ]
That's how they get you, man.
They make you buy a snow globe,
then you get through,
they take it away, then you buy
another snow globe."
[ Light laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] Finally,
you guys, I read
that Madison, Wisconsin
was just named
the most compassionate city
in America.
When asked how they felt
about it they said,
"Really sad for
the cities that lost."
[ Laughter and applause ]
We have a great show tonight.
Give it up for The Roots!